this evening the streaks of artillery
lit the sky of this border town the
Turkish army hitting Kurdish targets
just inside Syria the strikes began just
after four o'clock in the afternoon one
of the first targets Talib yet until
Sunday it was a Kurdish and US military
observation post now the Americans have
pulled out allowing the Turks to
demonstrate they are now taking control
here despite global calls for them to
hold back pictures from another Syrian
Kurdish town show the impact of the
strikes the Kurds claim there have been
civilian casualties there is no
independent confirmation of that yet
[Music]
Turkish jets have been in the air -
without leaving Turkish airspace they
can still strike Kurdish targets on the
other side from positions in the Turkish
town of actually we heard booms of
artillery as they hit what Turkey says
our YPG militia positions the Kurdish
fighters they've long wanted to destroy
but they are the same fighters who have
alongside the Americans and the British
been pivotal in fighting the Islamic
state terror group turkish President
Erdogan was briefed on the operation and
these images are designed to boost his
popularity a commander in chief and in
charge ground forces will now follow the
artillery over the border
as they headed south they passed support
this operation is popular here the
people share their president's view that
the Kurdish fighters are terrorists
the Turkish continued to insist that is
a responsible NATO member they are not
invading they're not annexing civilians
are not the target the motive they say
is to create a temporary safe zone but
to do that they will need to redraw the
map confronting and defeating the
Kurdish Syrian militia over there it is
something they've long wanted yet it
risks more chaos in a country that's
been battered for years in the hours
before the strike started Syrian Kurdish
civilians were on the streets calling
for international support to halt the
strikes the people here feel abandoned
by the United States and in an interview
with Sky News just before his base was
evacuated a spokesman for the Kurdish
fighters said the people here would
voluntarily be human shields the people
are already working and moving towards
the border area in order to create a
human shield against any Turkish
invasion and I think everyone is also
working to prepare itself for any future
operation and so a decision by Donald
Trump at the weekend to move his troops
out of the area has given space for his
ally Turkey to attack his other allied
The Curse a new dangerous strand of the
long bloody Syrian war is now underway
mark stone sky news on the turkey-syria
border